one of the stories that is most
incredible to me is that is the Taliban
activity in Pakistan ground report has
been covering this for a year and a half
we've been getting almost daily reports
of increased you know militant activity
in these areas we have a very we have a
very strong constituent base there
that's been reporting to us lots of
professional journalists and only just
now has the American media woken up to
the fact that okay we're in the midst of
a major crisis here but if if you'd
looked at ground report a year ago you
would have seen you would have seen all
of the indications that this was set to
happen I just mentioned that I was at
the NASA shuttle launch live streaming
with an inverse that satellite dish in a
laptop just enough stuff that you could
fit in a knapsack that was pretty
exciting some of the other breaking
stories that we've seen let's try to
think in in Zimbabwe we've been seeing
lots of signs of unrest we have a lot of
reporters there who are writing under
pseudonyms to protect their identity but
it will be anything from you know
there's mutiny among Mugabe 'he's
soldiers they're there they want to
break away to a general unrest among the
public things that wouldn't end up in a
newspaper in zimbabwe because people
could be an in danger but but that we're
very happy to publish and sort of
counter a call the disinformation out
there
we can't really take responsibility
because our model is not really giving
people assignments so much as allowing
them to publish their own work so in
contrast to something like Current TV we
don't send reporters and pay for them to
go places and equip them with all these
tools although we will sometimes give
people things like flip video cameras
etc we sometimes do outreach when
there's been a breaking event but it's
usually nothing that requires someone to
go to the scene of an event and we're
very cautious about listen your safety
is more important to us than anything
else so never compromise that in any way
will usually more take the event and say
okay what are people thinking about how
do people feel about this how have you
been affected personally because that's
that's what sort of takes takes the
event and and stops you from sort of
glazing over saying this is some big
international issue and saying wow
there's some emotional engagement there
that's that's a real person who's
experiencing it
absolutely that's that also plays into
the the safety question because you say
oh are you worried about people being in
Pakistan okay these are people who have
grown up in Pakistan and they're
probably the safest that anyone will
ever be because they have relationships
there so again that's exactly the kind
of mobile or digital or even citizen
reporter that we try to recruit is
people who already have their own
networks who are already very connected
in that region are able to speak to
people in decision-making capacities at
the at the head of any event that takes
place or able to sort of tell us here's
exactly what you know the head of the
police is saying here's what the head of
the local political party is saying and
maybe they are even part of those
political parties etc these these are
the kind of people who will really be
able to connect us in a way that a
foreign a foreign reporter never could
or foreign correspondent the other the
other side of that is they can get an
answer out of these people that may be
much more honest much more revealing
than than than a foreign reporter
our goal for working with developing
countries is more to acknowledge what
the situation is with their technology
and and sort of take advantage of that
in in the best way we can so for
instance in a lot of these countries the
mobile phone penetration is enormous so
instead of pushing them to do live
streaming video which is basically
impossible because they won't have an
internet connection that's fast enough
will push them to contribute via mobile
phone or or two to post to post reports
that way so we'll really focused on the
mobile capacities so when basically
every region in the world there's
different ways that we interact in
different tools that we encourage people
to use